so I'm Elijah I'm currently at Citrix I
run the machine learning platform and
yeah and I'm Stefan kavchick and so
formally of the team but uh with the uh
the two creators of Hamilton which we're
going to talk about today
I expect most of this talk to come from
Elijah I'm gonna pop in with any Salient
points and otherwise I'll be monitoring
uh chat channels uh and Discord um yeah
let's try to answer questions If I
Stumble he will jump in and help me
cool I'm gonna get started then
um awesome really excited to be here
with you
maybe talk about something I'm really
just interested in and have had a lot of
fun with and this is an open source
framework that we built it's called
Hamilton so I'm going to talk about how
it can help you build scalable feature
engineering and we'll dig into all of
what that means
so first uh take homes in case you fall
asleep for the rest of this uh I want to
convince you a that feature engineering
code is difficult so maintaining it uh
handling it over time scaling it that's
all just a complex thing hopefully
that's something you're familiar with
feature engineering code because it's
difficult to get into a loop where the
maintenance work on it is actually
harder than the building
of it uh so that you get to a point
where you're continually maintaining and
spinning and then building new features
is difficult
Hamilton was built to help you escape
that Loop and it's easy to get started
with and easy to use so before I jump
into anything else I want to stress that
we're not selling into anything to you
Hamilton is open source code
uh install it pipei conduct it's having
less than 15 minutes with a bunch of
great documentation and a lot of good
examples I've been putting some work
into this
okay so on the agenda today first I want
to tell you a story of uh the project
that motivated Hamilton which was a data
science team that was going through a
lot of pain at Stitch fix then I'll tell
you a little about the solution how it
works
and why we created it or how we created
it
next I'm going to talk about how it can
help you scale feature engineering uh
and by scaling I actually mean two
things we'll dig into what this means uh
one is scaling sort of with the
complexity of the business so scaling is
the human and team component gets more
complex and interesting and the other is
scaling the compute and data that you
handle so handling bigger data and
running on more machines
and finally I'll talk about the open
source progress and the next steps with
Hamilton like where we're going
so let's dig in
all right I first want to set the scene
and talk a little about the company I
still work at
um it's called Stitch fix and if you're
not familiar it's a pretty simple idea
so you create your style profile
meaning you fill out a form online and
you give us information about what you
like and what you don't like instead of
what might fit what am I not what you'd
like in the past then you get five
hand-picked items curated by both an
algorithm and a stylist to work together
to get you exactly what you want and
then there's a feedback loop so you keep
what you like and send back the rest
another Avenue that we introduced
recently is you can shop at your own
personal online curated store so
algorithms can help recommend
the clothing for you and you check out
what you like and return what you don't
uh so the interesting thing here is that
data science Powers pretty much
everything in the user experience
there's a lot of feedback loops where we
can learn a lot of recommendation
algorithms and we've kind of put data
science into every piece to optimize the
customer experience and optimize the
business
all right so data science Powers the
user experience and
but such we have 100 plus data
scientists and data platform Engineers
building out this building out this
offering building out this uh building
out the tricks so you can see you can
follow the blog it's called multi-thread
it's a cute little pun uh there's also
an algorithms tour that sort of shows
you how algorithms are woven into the
fabric of our fabric funds
so I want to talk about citrix's oldest
model which is a model that was
responsible for forecasting the business
as is forecasting demand sign ups and
churn so building off of the talk that
was just given
um and the structure looks something
like this right pretty standard machine
learning life cycle it's got your data
coming in from the business you mess
that around and turn it into a
featurized data frame uh fit some time
series models use those models to
predict the future and that generates a
data frame with a forecast your data
product you give to somebody else
well let's we're going to dig into the
featurized data frame part because
that's what was really giving them
challenges
okay
well this slides are animating weirdly
so I'm gonna have to
look here um
so what this looked like is a thousand
plus operations on a simple data frame
a lot of configuration buried in and
multiple layers of configuration and
sort of scripts to help you visualize
the data and there's a world-class team
running this so I I the animations got
me way to the lead here but the point
was what got them here wasn't going to
get them to the next place so they were
building this like highly complicated
set of operations that it was just
getting too complicated for them and too
much to manage the infrastructure itself
was getting to the point where they were
thinking more about that more about the
script shape and less about the actual
working analysis they were doing
so uh the
so like
so the problems what was going wrong
with this uh unit testing ended up being
very difficult and was almost never done
the whole thing was sort of put together
in one big monolithic script and not
separated nice since you could use a
test documentation was unnatural and
unenforced uh there was a lot of code
comments you kind of have to grab
through the code base and dig in and
really you're looking at the code to
figure out how it worked no comments for
you uh modularity was effectively
non-existent it was all sort of buried
together
to treat it as a data Cloud log you just
have to do a lot of regretting again if
you want to figure out how a piece of
data how a column was generated you'd
have to look through and figure out
exactly that from the code
to debug it you had to run the whole
pipeline uh no running an individual
piece and to do data validation
you had to run the whole pipeline as
well and this was not really done you
just sort of
after doing some initial research they
trust it was good and not have a sense
that it was continuing to work over time
so this is a good initial solution
because it helped them really quickly
get up to speed and they had a great
mathematical model that was powering but
along with time this turned into
spaghetti code
so what happens when you have all these
problems and you want to expand your
models to new regions you want to
forecast what the UK looks like you have
to add complex scenarios on management
Management's whim they want to start
seeing what if we up marketing spend
here sort of change the onboarding
workflow
you have a data bug and you have very
little time to solve it
and the answer was this really wasn't
fun I want to stress that this isn't a
unique experience to stitch fix time
series forecasting or even pandas this
is where we got our start but we're sort
of thinking more general purpose than
this and imagining that all of you can
kind of empathize with this
uh with this sort of feeling of
of things getting more complicated and
the infrastructure not quite supporting
it
so I don't know about you but this is
something that I've hit many times in my
life I don't always write complex data
pipelines when I do it turns into an
unintelligible mess of spaghetti code
the more and more I need to add to it
so let's talk about the solution we came
up with at Stitch fix
which we're calling which we called
Hamilton
okay so the moment
the the aha moment that we got was the
idea that what if instead of just
writing a bunch of columns as sort of
procedural lines in a file each one
correspond to exactly one python
function
and furthermore what if you could
determine the dependencies from the way
that function was coded so that's why we
came up with Hamilton uh in Hamilton the
artifact sort of column in this case but
it can be anything it can be more than
just pandas data frames in series is
determined by the name of the function
and its dependencies are determined by
the parameters so pretty simple we'll go
into what this means in a second
but here's what it looks like
in practice so instead of writing these
sort of procedural data frame
Transformations that you might be really
familiar with
you declare your
uh Transformations as functions and
write them out and again Hamilton
supports all python objects not just
data frames and series so instead of the
original way you've got your outputs
corresponding to the function name
you've got DFC reference to Def C there
and DFD corresponds to FD there and then
the inputs are the function arguments
hopefully pretty simple
and here's what the whole
uh hello world looks like so you don't
just write the functions there's one
more piece you write the driver
um the functions
are all sort of contained within modules
as modular and the driver says what and
when to execute
so you can see we uh import the driver
import those functions
run the driver
or instantiate the driver pass it any
configuration to get it started and the
functions you need to run and then run
the result and in this case we're going
to add a data frame but again it can
work with anything not just a series and
data frames
all right so the tldr here for each
transform
you write a function functions declared
directed acyclic graph a dag and if
you're not familiar with it what a dag
is it's just a way of sort of computing
this flow you can see on that right
there and Hamilton handles the execution
of these of this Dag
so we've got our functions we've got our
driver functions naturally form a dag
driver uh
runs these functions and we're good to
go
all right so there's more you might be
wondering okay if I have to write a call
a function for each column each artifact
that I have that's going to be a lot of
functions and what if all these columns
are like kind of repeated
um so my code end up being more verbose
I want to say two things so yes it might
but it's not always a bad thing that
said you want to keep your code dry you
want to not repeat yourself as much as
possible so when it is a bad thing we
have a lot of decorators to give you
higher order capabilities and pop-up
functions
so we have abilities to attach metadata
to parametrize to so this is sort of
like curries and repeats a function kind
of like a for Loop if you will
uh to extract columns so if you have a
function that outputs a data frame you
can turn that into multiple series
uh we also have one that I'm really
excited about which is data validation
so if you want to
assert that your data looks a certain
way at runtime you can use this check
output decorator it's extremely powerful
and plugs into a lot of Frameworks I'm
not going to go into it in this talk but
if you have any questions reach out
later I'm happy to talk about it I have
lots of good documentation
uh We've also got configuration ones to
make sort of the configuration and shape
of your pipeline simpler you can think
about this as an if statement in your
code whatever functions and we're adding
new ones all the time this isn't the
full set and we have a lot more so I'm
super excited about that
all right so to summarize and drive this
point home uh Hamilton forces you to
write transforms and python functions
and these python functions help you
decouple the implementation of your
logic from its execution
so they provide you everything you need
unit testing is simple you've got plain
old python functions you can test them
as you normally would documentation you
just use the docstring Citrix we have
this automatically generated
documentation process it's really
exciting
modularity everything's in small pieces
by definition and functions are
organized into modules
uh it naturally forms a data catalog so
the code is the central feature
definition star so if you want to figure
out where your feature is defined just
search it in the code it'll be real easy
and debugging is straightforward you can
execute functions individually add break
points and if you have I know there's a
problem in the data you can easily sort
of like Traverse the dag to
figure out what's going on and where it
might have started
and the data can be you can sleep well
that your data is going to be
trustworthy there's a lot of validation
included out of the box so decorators
provide powerful higher order operations
and the driver can decouple the
transform definition from the execution
making it so you write your transform
separately to how you run them and thus
only think about writing them or running
them not those at the same time
all right a Citrix has been really
successful we've been running in
production production for two and a half
plus years it's now three now
in the initial use case manages 4000
plus feature definitions uh data science
teams love it so it enabled a process of
monthly model and feature update for the
time series forecasting to go four times
faster so they get a lot of time back
and they can focus more on building
their models as opposed to running their
systems it's easy to onboard new team
members code reviews are nice and simple
it's sort of the code is very logical
and you can easily see how to function
change they finally have unit tests for
the first time and they have Auto
genomatically generated swings
documentation so they can understand
what their pipeline does a little fun
evidence here
um some eye candy on the left they want
to show this is an older one it's been
I'm sure the order of the commits has
changed since then but on the left is
the commits you can see I do like a
bunch of little commits so I helped
build it out at first
uh but since then Jason has written like
almost 200 000 lines of code so this is
a very big very complicated thing uh and
data scientists have taken it over which
is really exciting they love it they
work on it it's very natural to them and
the airplane on the right is their crazy
visualization of how the director
basically graph Works um this is the
most satisfying visualization of a
complex dag I've seen they've colored it
according to modules and tags and it
ends up looking really pretty
um not much you can pick up from that so
though so
that's a lie candy
all right uh so we talk about why we
created Hamilton we talked about what
Hamilton is and I want to talk about how
Hamilton can help team scale right or
help uh help you scale your feature
engineering Pipelines
so let's talk a little bit about feature
engineering what this looks like and so
look at the whole machine learning sort
of model life cycle
uh we've got a few components here so
the first part of featurization which
we're going to dig into you load the
data you transform it into features then
you might use that data to fit models
and use those models to
infer sort of running on other data but
it's predict the future
you can model the entire machine
learning more clone Hamilton we've seen
both Open Source cases and cases at
Citrix where they do that but on a focus
now on featurization so this works for
any python object type not just pandas
um but we're going to focus on pandas
because it's nice and simple right now
and it's embeddable anywhere python runs
you can run in orchestration systems
airflow Cube flow metaflow flight kit
prefect gagster we've even seen people
run it in flask caps where they want to
like cleanly represent their data flow
from request to response and that's
modeled in a Hamilton bag
cool so uh how do you model
featurization in Hamilton well a few
pieces of code that need to be written
two function files in the driver so
there's your functions to load the data
these sort of bring it in from your data
warehouse from SQL from the internet
wherever you get your data
you then write functions to transform uh
your data so take it from that raw form
into something that your model will be
useful and then a driver can materialize
it
and then you can execute only the pieces
that are needed right so you're like I
just want to write in the tables that go
or the columns that go into this table
run it we can run all the dependencies
and how often smart about that
right so why is this hard well as I kind
of got to earlier the difficulty here is
in scaling and
what do I mean by scaling well there are
two ways that we think about scaling and
I think this is kind of a novel approach
um I'm sort of excited about sharing
uh and Hamilton was built to solve one
and can help you solve the other
so there's the notion of human and team
challenges
so this is scaling up as the complexity
of your problem and it changes and as
the team changes and morphs around you
so this is dealing with highly coupled
code code that's coupled to
infrastructure and slows down your
velocity dealing with debugging uh
difficult difficulty debugging and
understanding workflows
um
handling messy collaboration on complex
pipelines is two people are editing at
the same time and trying to figure it
out and validating your data
yeah so Hamilton was actually built to
solve this problem
and was really built to help you scale
sort of into the complexity of your data
flow
but it also can help you solve the
compute challenges so if your data is
too big to fit in memory and you can't
easily paralyze computation Hamilton
allows you to integrate into a bunch of
powerful Frameworks that already exist
to do this again we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel there's spark Ray to
ask we're trying to talk about how all
those work in just a minute with
Hamilton
but we want to be able to use Hamilton
to give you the power of all these
distributed Frameworks and as Hamilton
is a nice sort of logical layer it makes
sense then delegate to these underlying
Frameworks thus giving you the ability
to scale both in complexity and in data
size
all right so how do we scale in the
human and team components that are sort
of scaling with the complexity of your
workflow
it's cool so Hamilton help you decouple
code uh either from infrastructure where
the driver handles execution and the
Hand the function handles business logic
a lot of the function modules handle
business logic allowing you to run the
drivers separately from writing the
functions
and Hamilton can help you decouple code
from itself so code is organized into
functions functions organized into
modules and the functions that you don't
know about Hamilton you can reuse them
anywhere if you're using Hamilton you
have a bunch of functions and you decide
you don't like it take those functions
elsewhere it'll be easy to string them
together
so you can see uh one really cool thing
is you can even have multiple drivers
running your functions in totally
different ways you've got your staging
you've got your prod you've got with
different databases pretty easy to work
with and pretty flexible
all right Hamilton could also make it
easy to debug so to knock bugs all you
have to do is Rerun the broken path so
if you see that dag there if span if the
spend zero mean unit variance is weird
you can start sort of like running up
and seeing what data is weird and thus
not have to deal with rewriting the
whole script and getting lost in it uh
python functions allow for a unit test
and natural debugging or you do testing
a natural debugging
it's really it's much easier to work
when you know your logic is sort of
contained within a few lines
it gives we give runtime data quality
checks so to be easy to debug and figure
out what was wrong quickly and then we
can quickly narrow the search space for
these data bugs that I've been saying
Hamilton can also help you understand
and visualize your pipeline so you can
visualize the data flow in the execution
path and clearly track dependencies
again it's all the dag and the dag is
easy to see you can see from
visualization but you can also just sort
of trace it up through the functions by
following the parameter names
happily makes it easy to collaborate
within a team so as it provides a
central feature definition store it
forces alignment on naming
the is everything is referred to by its
name once it's easy to think about and
sort of make that very natural
documentation documentation is included
in natural it's Again part of a python
doc strings
and minimize conflicts when
collaborating everything's organized
nicely into modules so you can both be
working on a pipeline at the same time
uh change and it makes change management
easier the feature versions are always
included in git so all changes are part
of git history and the PRS are easy to
read you can trace these back
to function so if you want to figure out
when something broke you can look back
do a bisect figure out exactly where
that broke and see which function
changed
all right so to sum of the scalability
with some code uh the whole goal here is
we want our things we write in Hamilton
to be very simple and easy to read so
hopefully this code is pretty
straightforward and it's clear and what
it's supposed to say is that the future
client type normalized defined above is
owned by the client recommendations team
you can see it's tagged contains no
personal identifying information the
gdpr concerns also tagged is of type
float there's our data track depends on
two Upstream features type zero mean and
height standard deviation has no null
Nan features and produces values in the
negative five to five range right
Version Control System choses to change
shows its changes over time and you can
grip the code base for Downstream
dependencies so there's a lot packed
here but the goal is we want to make it
so you don't have to look at like yaml
files functions script Etc it's all just
buried inside one simple function it's
easy enough to read and self-contained
so we talked about how Hamilton can make
your work as a team a little simpler and
help you scale how does it help you
scale the compute and data aspect
all right so the approach here is to
delegate and we have three Frameworks
we're going to talk about today we're
always sort of adding more
uh one set is Ray and dasks desk so they
can help you run in parallel and scale
from a single machine to running and
multi-processing to running in a cluster
and and this is great if you have sort
of a lot of different computations that
you want to offload
and then we also support pandas on spark
because it used to be called koalas and
this allows you to scale horizontally
for data set so if you have data that's
bigger than memory you can use Amazon
spark to help that happens probably
something you're familiar with and the
thing that I want to drive home I'm
going to be showing you this amount of
code in the next little bit is that
switching almost always only requires
changing driver side code and this is a
function of decoupling the functions
from the driver right so the idea you
write your functions then you can switch
to use these different Frameworks and
only change your driver side code
a slight caveat pentathon spark requires
changing of one small set of functions
as well I'll show you what that means in
just a minute
cool
so scaling with Ray uh what does this
look like let's take a look at a pretty
simple driver we do our import our data
loaders our date features and our spend
features
we've got a configuration that sets up
the driver the driver then runs with all
these models uh so date and spend are
sort of features that you can use in a
Time series forecasting model
uh choose the features you want just run
those and then materialize your data
right so extract transform load pretty
simple
what does this look like with Ray
so running on Ray just requires a few
simple additions to the driver
we import our Hamilton Ray extension
instantiate something called a graph
adapter which basically tells us how to
walk and execute the graph
we pass that into the driver
run everything just as we normally would
get in our future data frames
materialize it in the end shut it down
give your resources back to your friends
be a good citizen so nice and simple
only a few additions no change to the
code for Ray and now we've got something
that runs fully in parallel potentially
across a cluster
all right so what does this look like
with desk it's the exact same actually
uh We've
ex we import our Hamilton extension for
das create a graph adapter uh we
actually pass it a result Builder so we
can sort of put them all together on a
pandas data frame take them back
then we instantiate a driver and pass it
the Das graph adapter run it just as we
normally would shut it down give
resources back to your friends and we
have run everything in parallel using
desk
all right that's nice and simple what
does this look like on Amazon spark so
slightly more complicated there's uh one
one extra piece here but mostly it looks
the same so import your Hamilton spark
extension
create the spark sessions that your
options whatever you want to do
run your spark koalas graph adapter in
this case we're passing out a spine can
spark the notion of indexing As Natural
spark as it is the pandas
and let's pass that in the only other
difference is we're going to be passing
in a new set of data loaders that loaded
into a spark data frame so the rest of
the pipeline can work finally run our
features as we would save our data frame
stop it give your uh give your compete
back to your friends
and
close down the spark session so fairly
simple
um and what does this all look like how
does this work so we've got our
functions
and our driver right our driver loads up
our functions turns everything into a
directed acyclic graph
then we delegate to Ray and desk right
so the one simple trick of distributed
systems for us here is all we have to do
is call out to the apis within our graph
adapter as we walk the Das the dag
create a remote uh or desk delayed
similar things uh
allowing us to run and delegate over to
the Rand asked ecosystems
and with spark uh one more trick all you
have to do is change these to load spark
pandas equivalent objects instead spark
will take care of the rest
so it's nice and simple
cool
all right so are there a few caveats
here we're kind of working them through
serialization you have to use the
serialization methodology of the
underlying delegated Frameworks memory
should the default should work fine uh
fine to need a function level isn't
quite supported yet for python
dependencies you need to manage them we
don't have a framework get demand the
staff and we're looking to graduate
these apis from experimental status so
this is where we want contributions to
help extend support and happen yeah one
more I just realization on the um it's
on this it's uh the one of the things
you just have to think about also is
your data set size so some of these uh I
guess Frameworks you know do require
some sort of data or things operating at
scale so in which case if you have small
data and you want to you know quickly
parallelize things you might run into
kind of serialization costs but you know
we're still interested in people playing
that with no matter the data size in
terms of using these features so if you
have feedback if if something's not
working for you do let us know since you
know we have a few few ideas but would
love to kind of prioritize given
feedback
awesome thanks John
cool all right so how's the open source
stuff looking in where are we going next
all right uh Amazon progress early
stages but thriving Community we have
multiple high profile users IBM UK
government Digital Services British
cycling team Federal Reserve Pacific
Northwest National Laboratories Citrix
obviously and a bunch more that we can
list here it's 700 plus stars on GitHub
and a growing set of core contributors
but we're looking for more we want more
contributors uh more bug Hunters more
user feedback any way that you engage
we'd love because we just sort of get to
learn about the open source community
and give back and it's really exciting
and what's our vision where do you want
to go well I think we're looking at
being a unifying layer for machine
learning etls so Hamilton specifies a
logical way to to represent your data
flows
that's nice clean and easy to read but
it doesn't do everything in the vertical
here right it doesn't orchestrate for
you it doesn't sort of do external
storage and all that stuff
um so our goal is to be able to compile
to an orchestration framework right so
dagster prefect airflow metaflow these
are all great options I've used them all
before and Hamilton could allow you to
write an interface that would then plug
into these and run on these underlined
systems
uh we're gonna be able to integrate with
more data quality vendors and open
source options we have a few and it's
pretty straightforward but we want to be
able to add integrating with it say
arise or Y logs these are both great
things that I've worked with before
I want to make it so it's trivial to
load from a variety of Upstream sources
so all you have to do is build a little
adapter and load from snowflake load
from PB load from whatever data
warehouse you've got
another thing about adding more natural
SQL support one of the things I'm really
excited about docdb is it sort of
bridges the gap between SQL and python
allowing you to sort of seamlessly jump
between the two and I think some
Transformations and especially data
loading are fairly natural to
represented SQL so why not make that
more of a first class citizen
all right so getting there we're making
a lot of progress uh we have
a bunch of new decorators coming on all
the time we just released a decorator
that allows you to reuse a big portion
of your uh subdag and I'm working you're
starting to work on more natural SQL
support
as I said earlier and again we're
listening to uh requests users are
asking yourself all the time and we're
building them so happy to build stuff
that you might need
and then we're looking at more
informative execution so how can we
compile down and sort of specify this
data flow uh in a way that it can keep
our sort of decoupulation decoupling
from functions and materialization
and can we build sort of more fun user
interfaces that allow you to interact
with us and again if you have any ideas
we're all ears cool so give Hamilton a
try we'd love your feedback um please
give it a star on GitHub create an
urbane We Love We Love Our Stars uh
create and vote and issues on GitHub we
love sort of working with community and
join us on slack here's a link I can
send this to slides out later
um but it's also on our documentation
so thank you um
really appreciate your time if you have
any questions you can yell at me online
on Twitter connect with me on LinkedIn
code with me on GitHub and here's my
email use it sparingly thanks folks
really appreciate it thank you thank you
too definitely for coming out to this
conference
all right
yeah like one last minute
yeah happy to answer any questions